for the co-stars of actors who died
showing up to work without the person
you've been acting alongside for years
can be tragic
these actors were never quite the same
after their co-stars died
john belushi's death in 1982 was a
tragedy for his fans and the many people
who'd been lucky enough to work with him
but none of his former co-stars took the
loss harder than dan aykroyd eckroyd and
belushi worked side by side for years
and whether they were performing on
saturday night live or making music as
the blues brothers the two were an
unbeatable comedy duo decades after
belushi's death aykroyd still wishes
that somehow things had gone differently
for belushi
later in life ackroyd co-founded a chain
of music venues called the house of
blues
and aykroyd has publicly wished that
belushi was still around to be a part of
it
aykroyd said in an interview with the
guardian i think about him every damn
time i walk into a house of blues
why aren't you here man to enjoy all
this when chadwick boseman died at the
age of 43 from colon cancer his fans
were stunned
for boseman's black panther co-stars the
loss was overwhelming
michael b jordan who played killmonger
opposite bozeman's black panther was
deeply affected by boseman's death
during a 2020 interview with vanity fair
jordan said when reflecting on what he'd
learned
you want to do the most you can and get
the most out of the time that you have
uh and make it count while there is a
sequel to black panther in the works
currently scheduled for release in 2022
it won't be the same without bozeman
while starting in luke cage mike coulter
had the opportunity to work alongside
reggie kathy an accomplished actor who
was widely known for playing norman
wilson in the critically acclaimed drama
the wire
kathy was diagnosed with lung cancer
while they shot season 2
and died in february 2018 before the
season was released
although their time together on the show
was short coulter felt a genuine kinship
with kathy
coulter said during a panel at baltimore
comic con in 2018
reg was great i wish we got a chance to
spend more time together it was like
discovering a friend you didn't get a
chance to really hang out with i don't
know how he did it
coming on set physically being
completely worn out but at the same time
giving 100
in april 2020 the news broke that actor
sam lloyd had died just over a year
after being diagnosed with a brain tumor
and lung cancer
best known for his role as the nervous
lawyer ted on scrubs
lloyd had gotten married shortly before
his diagnosis and he and his wife
vanessa had welcomed their first child
despite his serious diagnosis lloyd's
loved ones and former co-stars hoped
that he would heal somehow
not long before his death lloyd's fellow
scrubs cast member zac braf ran into him
and thought he might be recovering
raff said in an interview with extra it
was just such a a sad story because he
was sick
just when he had like found true love
and had a baby it was just
such a sad story in july 2020 the death
of naya rivera
shocked glee fans who finally remembered
rivera for playing the witty and
ruthless cheerleader santana lopez in
the musical comedy series
rivera drowned while swimming with her
son josie and fans poured out their
condolences to her fellow gleek cast
members who were mourning her death not
only was jane lynch grieving over
rivera's death but she also stated that
her niece megan was close with rivera as
well
leaving the two of them struggling to
come to terms with what had happened
months later jane lynch who had played
sue sylvester on the series reflected on
the loss to access hollywood you could
have no better friend than naya rivera
the news of robin williams's death in
2014 shocked everyone
it was hard to believe that the man who
had spent decades making everyone laugh
was gone
matt damon who had worked with williams
on the academy award-winning film
goodwill hunting was particularly
affected by the loss
damon said that he felt that he owed his
success to williams and there was no way
for him to repay williams for taking a
chance on working with him and ben
affleck on goodwill hunting
he was regretful that he had fallen out
of touch with williams in the years
leading up to his death
damon said in an interview with yahoo
news i think everyone who wasn't there
with him at the end feels bad that they
didn't see it coming i hope i become
better at checking in with my friends
and i hope that we as a country get
better at checking in with each other to
prevent this kind of thing stand by me
is a classic 80s film and the cast grew
close while filming
but after shooting rapt will wheaton
river phoenix corey feldman and jerry
o'connell went their own separate ways
less than a decade after its release
phoenix died of a drug overdose and many
years later wheaton reflected
i didn't feel a real sense of loss at
the time the river i knew and loved had
been gone for a long time at that point
but i felt sad for his family and angry
at the people around him who didn't do
more to help him help himself
25 years after the release of stand by
me the cast reunited for a commemorative
blu-ray edition of the movie wheaton
said he finally felt the full impact of
river's death at this reunion that's
what it took to make his death and his
absence a real thing that i could feel
instead of an event that i wasn't a part
of but i'm forced to talk about more
often than i'd like
but despite feeling intense grief
wheaton was grateful for the reunion and
the realizations it brought to him he
just wished that river could have been
there too
leonard nimoy and william shatner worked
side by side on star trek playing spock
and captain kirk
they were friends for many years yet
they eventually grew apart and the two
actors even stopped speaking
but when nimoy died in 2015 shatner
admitted that they'd never mended their
friendship in an interview with the new
york daily news shatner said
until the day i die i will still wonder
what caused that rift after all the
years we had spent together after the
bond we had forged
what could i have done that was so
irreparable that he couldn't even talk
to me about it i just don't know and
it's sad and it's permanent
i don't know why he stopped talking to
me when the news broke that soprano star
james gandolfini had died in rome after
suffering a heart attack his fellow cast
members were devastated
tony soprano is an iconic tv character
and nearly two decades after the finale
aired there's no denying that the
sopranos has had a lasting influence on
prestige tv
after hearing about gandalfini's death
his co-star lorraine bronco who played
tony's therapist dr melfi
felt like she needed to take this moment
as a wake-up call she decided that she
had to turn her life around and start
practicing healthier habits
bronco connected with a friend who had
similar goals and the two embarked
on the journey together she ended up
writing a book about the experience
titled to the fullest the clean up your
act plan to lose weight rejuvenate and
be the best you can be
lauren mccall and humphrey bogart were
two of the biggest stars of the classic
hollywood film era it almost seemed like
fate that they would eventually fall in
love
after working together on the film to
have and have nots in 1944 sparks were
flying which was somewhat complicated by
the fact that bogart was married at the
time
shortly after the film premiered bogart
divorced his wife and married mccall
just a few months later
sadly after just over a decade of
marriage with mccall bogart died in 1957
both bacall and bogart famously had
affairs while married to each other but
their chemistry was still undeniable
mccall did remarry a few years after
bogart's death he had her second husband
jason robart still referred to her as
the widow bogart she never truly got
over bogart and in her memoir be myself
mccall wrote no one has ever written a
romance better than we lived
beloved actor philip seymour hoffman
tragically overdosed and died in 2014
among the countless peers who mourned
him was george clooney who worked with
hoffman on his film the ice of march
in an interview with abc news clooney
stated that the last time he saw hoffman
was a few months before his death
the two had dinner together in berlin
and clooney noticed that hoffman wasn't
quite acting like himself but he didn't
realize just how much his friend was
struggling
he seemed to have been having a tougher
time you know and there's no
understanding what goes on in an
individual's mind in their lives
when disney channel star cameron boyce
passed away after a fatal seizure it was
a harrowing wake-up call for his
co-stars
boyce died young he was only 20 and he
should have had an amazing life and
career ahead of him
his descendants co-stars couldn't
believe that he was gone dove cameron
who played mal and considered boyce a
close friend said that his death
reminded the cast just how precious life
is
cameron explained to today i think
that's kind of how we're all feeling is
we want to make an effort it really
reminds you how important everybody is
how important your one life is cameron
also got a tattoo to remember boyce
she chose a design with a flower coming
out of a gun an international symbol for
peace and anti-war movements
she stated that boyce was working with
an organization against gun violence
before his death and she wanted to
memorialize him as someone who cared
deeply about peace
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you